hello and welcome this is active model
stream
15.0 with Andrew Pasa from ABM to active
inference inference-based action
selection so Andrew thank you for
joining looking forward to this
presentation and overview so go for
it awesome thank you so much Daniel uh
yeah again I'm Andrew a and I uh I am a
full-time data analyst SL scientist
engineer uh many roles to fill when
working in the nonprofit world and uh so
a couple months ago I gave a uh a
workshop like a full uh talk on
constructing active inference agents
using the pmdp library as we'll be using
here today um and uh during that talk I
described
how we might be able to employ active
inference agents uh whenever putting
together agent-based models uh in the
context of computational social science
and so you'll see some links in the
description referring back to that
tutorial that I gave including my GitHub
which has all uh tutorial materials uh
on that page as well as some in browser
Google collab scripts that run python
code and so you can actually follow
along
um a lot of these uh learning resources
including this talk I'm giving are sort
of part of a a personal initiative I've
taken to try and uh create and develop
and then share open- Source learning
resources for applying active inference
um I see so much potential as someone
coming from more of a social sciences
economics oriented background uh you
know for for applying active inference
agents in areas where maybe they haven't
been employed too much before um and as
active inference is beginning to be
increasingly applied to uh social
science research such as uh you know
attempting to study and and
simulate uh something like human
behavior and decision making uh I
thought that that conference was a was a
really ripe opportunity to try and uh
make those kinds of connections for
people and and just kind of get those
kinds of dialogues moving um and
so for me as someone who came to active
influence with that kind of background
but also strong interest in cognition um
I just really wanted to uh kind of do
some from scratch sort of tutorials on
how to construct agents um you know as
someone who's been interning with active
inference Institute for nearly a year
now um and I'll also be giving a talk at
her upcoming posium which itself will be
a kind of extension of that tutorial I
gave a couple months ago as well as the
talk I'll be giving now um yeah I would
just like to uh really make it plain for
people sort of the general mechanics
that go into constructing active
inference agent uh I would also refer
people back to the textbook that was
published a couple of years ago by uh
pulo par and Carl friston um it's freely
accessible you'll find links to it in my
uh slides as well as in the collab
scripts if you follow the GitHub link um
a lot of material that I'm using to
construct these tutorials is actually
coming from that textbook so anyone
involved with the Institute uh reading
group uh where we cover the textbook
will uh kind of feel hopefully a little
at home whenever they follow these
tutorials um so we'll start off now um
we'll be constructing uh the longer span
of the tutorial is one uh make the
connection between active inference and
agent-based modeling agent based
modeling is a very common Paradigm in
computational social science uh that
said and this is not doing it justice
but I'm saying this just to keep it
brief uh in some ways it's very
traditional in the uh kinds of
assumptions that it makes more often
than not about human behavior uh often
times people rely upon a kind of
homoeconomicus or or self-centered uh
utility maximizer kind of a description
of what defines human decisionmaking and
um I think that that loses a lot of the
sort of richness that we find in
cognitive science neuroscience and and
Behavioral Studies uh of how people
might actually make decisions and active
inference supplies us with you know um a
rather you know simple assumption it's a
very complex assumption that being free
energy minimization whenever you break
it down but ultimately that's a core key
assumption that we're making and we
don't have to make a ton of additional
assumptions beyond that whenever
considering how to simulate uh uh human
behavior Beyond how do we construct our
model right or how do we construct our
agent and so um that's that's sort of
the connection that I'm making here
between agent based modeling and activ
inference then after that I describe how
what I did with that tutorial was I
recreated uh this kind of paradigmatic
uh simulation published back in 2007 uh
by uh by doctors laser and fredman uh
you'll see links to that paper as well
at the GitHub site uh through the link
and uh what they do is that they set up
what I would deem to be a so-called
traditional uh social science
agent-based model
where um agents are basically
pre-programmed to do particular things
um they don't exhibit autonomous
decision making which is sort of the
promise of a lot of generative AI today
uh and I think that active inference
especially emphasizes that sort of
autonomy in the sense that these are
agents who are you know minimizing their
own free energy and then from there you
know predicting what should be um the
next action that they should take or or
set of actions meaning a policy that
they should take and uh and so they
engage in all these kind of cognitive uh
functions or or mechanisms that we we
find humans to have related to to
planning and um uh the idea of having
habits that you build up over time and
how those sort of compete with more
deliberate decision making and um you
know the kind of uh executive
functioning in the prefrontal cortex of
the brain and and finding those kinds of
connections so um
without further Ado what we'll do now is
simply create one agent and um we'll
I'll go through the steps of how to do
that and uh this is the agent that
features in the uh laser Freedman model
Recreation that I do where I use active
inference agents uh as opposed to the
kind of pre-programmed agents that that
they use um
so um we'll start with saying again this
is
pmdp the link is there we import some
libraries um It's relatively not too
many and some of them are just for like
the plots um the main thing is you can
pip install
pmdp uh there'll be mentions later but
there have been many updates to that
Library over the past couple of years uh
and a little bit more context on PDP as
far as I understand it from a couple
conversations with the developers is
that this package is uh directly
inspired by and in certain ways trying
to emulate the mechanics of uh the SPM
package uh developed by by friston at
all uh in mat lab for for constructing
active inference agents and environments
and processes so um it's it's it's sort
of the Exemplar python library for doing
active inference as far as I'm aware um
and
that said there's so much complexity
whenever uh these libraries are
constructed and a lot of you know
dependencies between different like subl
libraries and so on so it it becomes
really useful to find more focused sort
of snapshots of how to construct say an
agent and understanding how those
mechanics work without necessarily
having to scavenge through the code that
said uh there are some examples and
example tutorials given at the PDP
website it that I've linked there on the
screen uh so please uh feel free to
peruse those um and so moving on from
there uh for anyone familiar with the
textbook uh it's very useful to refer to
Chapters six and seven uh chapter six
refers to uh kind of providing a general
recipe for constructing uh a agents and
environments and running
simulations um and uh then from there
chapter 7 kind of expands upon those
ideas by specifically creating partially
observable markup decisionmaking proces
processes or uh
pdps after which pmdp kind of cleverly
takes its name and um those are the kind
of discrete time discrete State space uh
models that we'll be working with that
is they they uh play out uh in action
perception Loops uh one time step at a
time as opposed to it being continuous
time so you could say you know at time
step one or t equals 1 uh and then at
time step two this happens times step
three this happens and then discrete
State spaces meaning that uh we're not
looking at continuous variables from
continuous distributions per se we're
looking at uh probability Mass functions
and you know just more concrete like you
know there's a hidden State uh Factor
called color and it has two levels red
and blue you know these kind kind of
definitive discreet uh uh factors and
levels so uh to construct an active
inference agent uh probably the this is
the general outline all smashed into one
slide uh so the first three steps
defining States defining observations
defining controls action policies um
with the nuances for all three of those
additional terms so States what are our
agents uncertain about uh what kind of
you know sets of beliefs do they hold
that they end up inferring and updating
potentially learning over time uh and
then defining observations what do our
agents observe from their environment
right um it's not enough to like claim
that you have an active inference agent
and throw it into some you know ethereal
space where it has no
sensory receptors no sensorium you know
you need to be able to Define like what
are uh senses so to speak that the agent
has available uh the technical phrasing
being observation modalities so for
example uh an agent might have um you
know a visual uh uh observation modality
where it can take in discrete levels uh
rain or no rain meaning at any given
moment it's observing if there's rain or
no rain uh through its visual
observation modality or visual sensory
receptor being able to clearly Define
those kinds of connections almost as if
we could view them on a graph which we
will do momentarily um and then defining
control action policies for all intents
and purposes going forward I'm going to
be relying upon the word actions um
that's because actions are simply in
this case discrete actions an agent can
take at a given time step um there's
nothing more to it than that uh you can
walk or you can run or you can sit
uh those would be three actions that an
agent could do at any given time step
right they're not doing multiple of
those in the same time step and they're
not uh doing them in any kind of
deterministic way so to speak um so with
controls that's a term that comes up
very frequently in the literature and it
also relates to other ways of doing say
uh reinforcement learning related to
engineering problems or otherwise but
the the idea of a control is that it's
just an action with kind of an
additional Nuance to it that uh it
relates to the idea of this is an action
that can actually change or control
something that something being a hidden
state or hidden State Factor um so it's
you know
whenever kind of putting together the
matrices involved in constructing PDP
agents uh there are times where you'll
need let's say a and we'll I'll clarify
what some of these words mean for for
anyone who's who's still new to to uh
modeling here um but uh so with controls
like there might be it might be the case
that you need some kind of subarray like
a b Matrix or submatrix that um you know
doesn't really do anything like it might
be a hidden state for a rat in a teamat
uh who you know they they know that they
can control which location of the
teammates they go to they could go to
the left arm they could go to the right
arm but they don't necessarily think
that they can change the location of the
reward it's always either on the left or
it's on the right and you don't know
until you see it right so it's it's like
the control there would be choosing the
left or right arm and the left or right
arm is the correct option being like the
uh or rather the the left or right arm
in state where the rat infers if it's
gone left or gone right like that is
something you can control moving on with
policies policies are sequences of
actions in this case you could have um
you know in the teamas you have a rat
who can choose to go left and then stay
there it can choose to go right and stay
there it could choose to go to the queue
and then go left uh or otherwise but the
idea is it's just a sequence of actions
uh and so uh agents can have their own
sort of hypotheses so to speak about
individual policies and that's very
interesting to think about whenever
we're considering active inference
agents who you need to engage in kind of
longer term planning Horizons and and
who might be used for you know imagine
uh for people who are into engineering
or or otherwise might be looking at a
like a like scheduling problems or you
know inferring situations where you know
that you're going to need to do a series
of actions in a sequence that maybe need
to have some kind of coherency with one
another such that it's useful to refer
to that specific spefic set of actions
as a policy um so Define States Define
observations Define your actions after
that we relate those three components of
a model uh via a series of uh
categorical probability distributions
which are in the a b c d and e uh
matrices um again all these feature in
the the textbook and then uh th those
will comprise the beliefs of the
agent then we Define our environment
which here we're not going to uh for
through the sake of today for the
shorter uh talk we're we're not going to
get too far into defining an environment
uh I will say that common ways of
defining environments especially
whenever you're just beginning the
modeling process is that oftentimes
people will actually construct another
PDP which itself represents the
environment because in that way can take
in its own observations those being the
actions of the agent and then it can
output its own actions those actions
being the observations for the agent
that's forming kind of squaring the
circle on our action perception Loop um
but uh for the sake of today we'll just
be looking at a fully deterministic
environment where I manually have it
take certain inputs send out certain
outputs it's still an environment it's
just not a very complex one
uh and then after that we just Define
the active inference Loop run it as a
simulation runs the full loop agent
receives observations in first States it
learns first policies it commits in
action then after that uh good modeling
practice if you're actually trying to to
do something with what you're modeling
uh and and trying to model some real
phenomena is that you would look at the
results of your uh simulation you would
look at what makes sense to you what
doesn't Maybe maybe there's some
parameters that uh don't quite make
sense that you've set up for the agent
maybe it's missing an observation
modality um or or otherwise or uh if
you're you know using these simulations
in a in a kind of more productive way to
to derive insights then the idea is that
you could tune things and you could
modify the environment as if you're you
know um uh uh introducing some kind of
intervention and then you could see how
things play out differently right in the
case of people who are maybe concerned
with with policy design or or kind of
analyzing uh agent Behavior under uh
various kinds of
conditions uh the agent we'll be
constructing today is uh an agent whose
task is to find a good solution to a
complex task of problem uh the idea is
that uh the Fuller idea is that they're
trying to navigate what's called an ink
landscape which is you know you could
you could visualize this as a broad set
of
solutions and each of them has its own
Fitness value so we're looking now at a
fitness landscape at any given point in
time in the Fuller simulation which I'll
cover in maybe future talk is that at
any given time an agent has a solution
currently um it can for the sake of this
talk I'll say it as simply as this the
agent can either at each discrete time
step during the action perception Loop
they can either explore meaning they try
to find a new Solution that's better
than the one they currently have or they
can exploit their neighbor which means
they steal their neighbor answer um this
is for more context this is useful for
understanding like if you wanted to uh
put agents into a network where they
interact with one another which is
precisely what my multi-agent simulation
from the tutorial does again uh review
the GitHub uh all the code is there for
doing so uh the rest of the slides in
this particular slide deck also uh get
into that but we're only focusing on
these um so the the agent can explore or
exploit and a quick note as well that
let's be cautious not to confuse the use
the words explore and exploit here with
how they appear in a lot of the
literature uh on the explor versus
exploitation problem um here we're just
going to say those are the names of the
agent actions they could be replaced
with study or cheat right um but I'm
just I recreated uh the laser Freeman
model they use explore exploit it makes
sense in a particular way and so we're
going to stay with that um after that
the agent will infer an intention hidden
State uh that is they'll they'll receive
observations uh from their environment
they they they chose to explore or
exploit they receive observations as a
response from their environment they'll
infer a hidden State and then they'll
learn meaning they'll update the the the
parameter values of their a matrix or
likelihood
Matrix um move to this this is much more
representative of the process so we can
start at the top the agent explore or
exploits
environment takes in those actions and
then based on uh based upon whatever
rules you set for it to have or you
could again you could construct some
kind of you know generative model um
that you know will kind of do it on its
own uh follow you know you could add
stochasticity or some kind of you know
error term or something so that it's you
know it's it's not entirely
deterministic however you like um but it
will generate observations at any time
step the agent after committing an
action it being sent the environment the
environment processing that action the
environment will send back two
observations to the agent um these upper
to Improvement or no improvement showing
that oh the agent explored for example
and then saw an improvement in its
solution to the problem and then or no
improvement you know and then uh the
other observation is self or neighbor
which is a one toone uh uh mapping that
is if you explore it's going to return
self if you exploit it's going to return
neighbored the idea is this agent has
two observation modalities one of the
first one relates to the quality of
their solution uh and and outcome of
their action uh and and then the second
observation modality simply is a kind of
self-reflexive
uh observation which is who did I attend
to after that the agent will take those
observations to infer hidden state it
only has one hidden State Factor uh that
contains two levels self and neighbor uh
there will be again a onetoone mapping
between self and neighbor if you see the
outcome you attended to yourself then
you're going to infer that you attended
to yourself vice versa for neighbor um
and then in addition to that inference
learning occurs uh which uh modifies the
uh categorical probability distribution
describing uh the the probability of
those outcomes given State beliefs and
the agent from there infer actions or
policies you should take and carry them
out and we
proceed so this and there will be times
that I might Zoom through particular
slides um but in this case this is one
that's good to reflect on um something
that I think a lot of people Miss uh or
or maybe struggle with uh having been
involved with the Institute the reading
group for some time and having my own
trials and errors and in learning how
these things work uh is that there's a
lot of nestedness we're working with a
lot of uh
matrices uh anyone who not only works
with PDP uh but also math lab and SPM is
is very familiar that it's it's crucial
to be able to understand how to
construct matrices how to construct
matrices that represent categorical
probability distributions I.E for the
agent their beliefs um and uh and so
it's it's really important to wrap your
head around that and so I just really
wanted to spell things out and there's
an additional collab script that I'm
currently writing that already has now a
bunch of markdown cells so that you can
not run the code uh but you can see like
full descriptions on how these things
work um all I'm basically adding more
things to to that script that that
weren't available uh to me or or I just
didn't have time to include uh one of
our devices initial tutorial um but now
that we've uh defined our hidden States
observations and
controls um we'll link them together
through the a b c d and e matrices
and so hidden States uh a clarification
on
terminology uh agents will have hidden
State factors they're they're called
hidden State factors they'll have uh you
know say and hidden State factors and uh
and and so our agent has only one it's
the attention hidden State Factor
containing two uh discrete levels uh
self and neighbor you see the same exact
kind of nestedness with OB observations
and observation or sometimes referred to
as outcome modalities so you'll have M
observation modalities our agent has two
of them one of them is for outcomes uh
which uh the discrete levels of which
are Improvement and no improvement as I
showed before um this code actually
includes a third one called
unobserved uh it never comes up in any
of the simulations I run I thought it
would be interesting though to include
it if only because it shows that you
know you can include uh additional
dimensions in your model even if you
don't know if they're going to come into
play at any point the simulation uh it
can potentially change things depending
on how you set those initial values in
in the uh belief
distributions but uh you know for the
time being I just wanted to show that uh
it's possible to do that and finally uh
controls and control factors uh so
actions uh you know again as I earlier
an action is just a discret thing an
agent can do you could have similarly
with nestedness you could have a whole
control factor of different actions an
agent could take with a total of f
control factors our agent will only have
one and it'll contain two discrete
levels or discrete actions explore and
exploit as far as defining hidden State
factors hiden States observation
modalities observations and then
controls or actions um this is it this
is all the code youi um that's part of
the and I'm following a certain kind of
Gom clature that PDP uh the developers
use in their tutorial website it's a
it's a very clever way of keeping track
of things um none of these string values
like self it's uh Improvement none of
them matter so to speak um they're just
a good point of reference
by uh including them in a list so this
first list attention state names
represents the hidden State Factor uh
for attention and it just it the list
contains two discrete levels self or
neighbor I included one in this
simulation to note you have one neighbor
so neighbor one uh and then from there
you just store uh the number of states
uh for each instate Factor uh this is
appears a little redundant because we
only have one but I'm just you know this
if you were to add like say multiple
hidden State factors this would be more
interesting um and then tracking the
number of hi State factors that you have
um for anyone who unfamiliar with Python
Programming the lane Len uh method
allows you to just see what is the
length of the object that you're
inputting so we only have uh one hidden
State Factor which leads us to uh
one the next small code snippet very
similarly now we Define each observation
modality the outcome observation
modality has three discrete levels
Improvement no improvement as I
mentioned earlier
unobserved the attention observation
modality contains two discrete
observations cell for neighbor one so
recall that in a given time step an
agent is going to receive one of each of
these so at uh you know time step four
the agent could receive Improvement and
name one or could receive no improvement
and self or unobserved in s the point is
that it will receive one of each right
um again we track those using uh the
length or Len uh function and then once
again actions uh we put them we only
have two actions so I just referred to
it as the action uh control factor and
we included our two actions you can
explore or you can exploit neighbor one
and we track that the number of controls
available to the agent um again that
that's it and and if you can determine
you know this kind of design for your
agent early on uh and then begin
programming I mean as as the authors of
the textbook acknowledge uh it's quite
an iterative process whenever it comes
to to computational modeling of just
about anything that includes active
inference agents and and running uh you
know simulations and and so on so um
this is a very crucial First Step
because it'll inform a lot of what you
do next as well as you know what you
might end up changing during that
process of of iteratively you know
changing your your model of your
model so the a matrix is the first step
of linking these things the a matrix
will link together the observation
modalities and hidden State factors uh
that we defined earlier we need one sub
array for each outcome modality so I
want to just draw attention to this
upper right equation um again Matrix
operations are perhaps the the main
hurdle in learning how to construct imdp
um agents or any PDP agents including
matlb um so a useful rule of thumb is
just remembering that whenever you
construct uh a matrix to represent say U
you know the a matrix the likelihood
Matrix uh you know that the probability
of whatever outcome you're looking at
whatever observation modality you're
looking at we'll start with the outcome
one which again uh includes Improvement
no improvement none observed the
probability uh of any of those
observations conditioned
on every single one of your hid State
factors which nicely for us is as simple
as uh the the way it looks to the far
left which probability observation
modality outcome uh conditioned on the
hidden State factor for attention right
so we're really just uh working with
these these two Dimensions um it it
would become threedimensional matrices
if say we had two hidden State factors
this would get expanded um so uh the
typical way of doing this in PDP uh PDP
contains a subl library utils uh
containing just different utility
functions and the the sort of framework
for constructing these kinds of uh
beliefs in p M DP is by using what are
called object arrays which are already
available in the numpy library uh it's
effectively a numpy array that allows
for uh data types aside from float
values so it's kind of a more flexible
version of a numpy array um and that
allows you to do things like say create
um an a matrix that's your
representative of your
overall likelihood Matrix for everything
all observation modalities and state
factors and then you can construct
within it individual
subarrays one for each observation
modality and that those subarrays can be
of different uh dimensionalities from
one another and so it's it's just again
wrapping your head around kind of the
nestedness here um and a lot of these
things are better represented in the the
code I've written so might touch on that
if there's time um uh of course this is
code I wrote too with the the collab
script which uh contains code that you
can run and it has different ways of
expressing these different matrices but
you can see the point is that we're now
that we've defined our hidden States our
observations our actions we're going to
start linking them and to represent our
agent beliefs so uh for this situation I
print the outputs
all code that you've seen so far with
the gray shading that is uh you know at
the beginning we imported libraries and
then two slides ago we um we looked at
defining H State factors observation
modalities actions now this is our a
matrix um I'm not getting into the maths
on this a matrix because it's easier to
just look at the outcomes um this is how
we've construct like all this code that
I've shown so far can just be run like
in the order that I've shown it thus far
you'll see that in the collab script um
here the first subarray again which is
for the outcome observation modality
we'll notice for those who are familiar
with probability Theory
um probability distribution sum to
one uh that that's help what's helpful
is that the utils uh subl library has is
normalized uh function where you can put
any object array into it it'll tell you
if it's normalized or not so helpful
rule of thumb to ensure that you've done
everything right before you proceed
further um and so what this does is that
it lets us see that if we sum these
values um each
outcome uh per pin state level uh we can
see that it's entirely uniform it's it's
totally uncertain it's not useful to the
to the agent there's a third probability
that they'll see an improvement if they
attend to
themsel third probability if of there
being no improvement if they attended
themselves there's a third probability
of seeing an unobserved outcome if they
attended them um it's very common
practice if you're attempting to model a
more realistic um you know phenomena or
or or organism or human and you have no
idea what they would do uh it's CA
practice initialize them with uniform
priors here I'm just doing it for the
sake of Simplicity and a in a tutorial
right um and so uh meanwhile with the
next subarray as I said earlier uh
there's one toone mappings between the
uh attention observation modality and
the attention hidden State Factor so it
it's as if the agent has
completely certain beliefs like the
polar obosa
uh about um about who it's attending to
right so if it sees that it's attending
to someone um attending to itself then
it will infer its intend attending to
itself and vice versa for
neighbor and that's it uh that's the a
matrix and then we have the B Matrix
which I would say is equally complex and
then Things become immensely simpler
from
the B Matrix again equation top right um
uh we need one subarray uh B Matrix for
each hidden State Factor this is very
simple we only have one hidden State
factor it's the attention hidden State
Factor um and so our agent wants to be
able to track um if I'm currently
attending to let's say myself and I
choose to explore what will the hidden
state be at the next time step thus s to
plus one conditioned on
sent the hidden State present uh
combined with pi which is representative
of the action or policy undertaken in
the present um this is also going to be
incredibly simple it's really going to
be one to one so at any given point in
time um the agent will
believe that regardless of what state it
is
in uh currently it will transition to
self if it chooses explore probability
one if it was in if the current state is
neighbor it'll transition to self with
probability one if it chooses explore
and similarly it always believes that
it'll transition to the neighbor in
state if
um regardless of whatever in state it
currently believes it is in so uh a a a
comment that that might come up for
anyone who is familiar with these things
this is not terribly uh different from
just a standard Markov decision-making
process right it's kind of like well if
the agent has all these fully certain
beliefs why create a partially
observable environment um there there
there's a certain reason for that and
then there's another just more direct
reason for that the direct one is that
this is how pmdp Works um and then also
I the the other reason is I think that
partially observable environments are
more representative of our reality I
think it aligns with the idea that we do
often have noisy sensory receptors uh
you know whether you have 2020 Vision or
not uh it doesn't mean that you can uh
you know see every color that's every uh
ever existed and it doesn't mean that
you know you can see perfectly anything
uh and so the idea of just this noise
being there and the idea that you have
to infer you have to rely upon
observations to infer beliefs and having
those kinds of Loops you know it all um
kind of makes sense and then there's
another aspect uh that will come up soon
whenever we discuss
learning for the C Matrix which is uh
representative of preferences or priors
over observations
this is basically denoting uh it's as if
we're saying uh what are the outcomes
the agent actually wants to see like or
observe what are the what are the
observations it wants to to to see
happen uh as oppos to those that it
doesn't right and so this is immensely
uh easier to construct uh versus the the
a matrix or the B Matrix um in that
we're really just effectively creating
these vectors
um so we need one subarray for each
outcome modality or observation modality
for the first one uh the outcome
modality the way that we've defined this
is take a list uh each one of these
values is indexed to the observation in
the
outcome uh observation modality as we
saw before so recall in order the first
one is Improvement the second one is no
improvement and the third one is
unobserved these line up exactly uh in
the same way and uh reiterating Again
The Matrix
operations uh and and being able to
grasp like how indexing goes here uh as
long as everything lines up uh it it'll
be solvable right the the the free
energy calculation will be able to be
carried out as long as everything kind
of is in its place right so so it's uh
do your best to never confuse uh you
know which position each of these
represents so the reason why these
values don't sum to one uh common
practice uh that I've seen a lot in
previous mat lab scripts and so on is U
uh people will actually use these like
whole integers and even negative values
because it's just kind of a more human
friendly human interpretable way of of
experimenting with an agent's
preferences um whenever you run this
through the soft Max function uh which
which is also applied here this
basically strongly
amplifies um the the final probability
distribution that that arises and also
turns it into a probability distribution
that does SU to one um and then uh
before we move on to see what that looks
like for the second observation modality
uh the attention observation modality
we're going to make that entirely
uniform as well what each of these
really is saying is that the agent
strongly prefers to see improvements in
its solution it dis prefers seeing uh no
improvement in its current solution and
it is indifferent to um to the
unobserved observation it's not exactly
how the math would play out because of
the softmax function but it's
effectively something like that and in
any case in this simulation we won't be
uh seeing the the
unobserved um observation come up at all
anyway and then for the second one uh
fully uniform preferences uh that simply
means that the agent has no particular
preference towards um whether it's
attending to itself or to its neighbor
right so you could experiment with this
you could see like what what happens
whenever an agent actually prefers
to do uh its due diligence and and
primarily just explore and come up with
its own answers to the to the solution
or what if you come up with an agent who
more so prefers to steal their or
exploit their neighbors's answer in any
case here we'll just we'll stay totally
um agnostic to uh that and just say that
the agent has uniform preferences so
those end up looking like this um
whenever we print them out uh again
these are normalized uh we see how the
softmax uh function strongly Amplified
uh where where where this uh the the
preference for improvement was a five
it's now become a
0998 continuing uh probability and so so
this relates back to the idea that
agents are self- evidencing they will uh
based on how particularly expected free
energy is computed uh where it includes
C uh within the pragmatic value term um
this is what will guide the agent
towards uh you know towards observations
that it prefers as opposed to others uh
making this move Beyond just uh you know
an agent who's hyperreactive to what's
going on in the present instead of an
agent who might uh prefer to uh see
certain things and therefore act in a
way to kind of realize what it prefers
again here uh preference really just
meaning it being what you expect um and
then again uniform distribution for um
for the second uh modality it has no
particular preference towards observing
itself or uh observing its neighbor as
who it's attending
to then D fortunately for us we only
have one hidden State Factor so this is
the shortest description it's similarly
to how C was a uh you results in a
probability distribution that uh
describes the prior over observations
the D Matrix does the same thing but for
States and we only have one hidden state
so we just have one sub array for uh the
attention hidden State factor and um you
know so again we just uh and I didn't
mention this earlier the the np. ons is
just generating um a vector
uh equivalent to the number of hidden
State levels that you have so a vector
of two ones and then you're normalizing
it using the utils library right so take
two ones normalize them you're going to
end up with
0.55 the ematrix are your habits uh you
don't actually necessarily have to
Define these uh whenever you're you're
constructing a pmdp agent uh I find it
to be very useful if either one you
actually want to uh you know uh run some
kind of experiment where you think that
the agent will actually have more of a a
sort of uh a habit of doing one
particular action over the other um it's
also useful if say you're trying to set
up a different kind of simulation that's
more focused on uh policies in which
case you know it might be the case that
you know you only want uh the agent to
have a strong prior belief for entire
particular policy versus another uh and
and use that as a way to to define the
agent as having beliefs that you know a
particular policy won't at all work
versus one that will such as um you know
uh dry off and then jump in the pool as
a kind of an odd thing to do um or or
you know could come up with some better
example in the fly but I I think the
point comes to cross right so in any
case this is just basically your priors
over your actions that get Incorporated
so what did we do uh we we we related
States and observations in the a matrix
we related States and actions in the B
Matrix uh and then C D and E are just
the priors on States uh excuse me
observations States and actions
respectively um also recall uh from the
from the textbook and elsewhere that the
agent has a separation from its
environment uh called the notion of a
marov blanket and so uh for the for the
agent UHS like despite certain things
occurring during free Min energy
minimization to where uh observations
and actions do in fact end up
influencing one another
vicariously uh we have not expressed a
probability distribution that actually
directly links observations and actions
so it's kind of maintaining the blanket
States of uh of your active state
sensory States and and you'll you'll see
that in the textbook uh reading the the
section about marov blankets so it's
just maintaining that that kind of
Separation then um I will go just a
little bit longer than what I expected
um so now that we have our a b c d and e
um one additional thing that our agent
will do is that it will learn uh you
know the idea of learning an active
inference uh there's plenty of
literature on this but it can relate to
you know the idea of for the sake of a
model what we're doing is that where're
we're assigning sort of these
hyperparameters or priors to uh to the
uh matrices that we just Define
themselves right so what our more
specifically what our agent will do is
it will learn its a matrix the
likelihood Matrix that we Define first
out of the those five things a BC D and
E
and uh it it will just update it based
on the new observations it receives and
the in state that it infers um and it
will also answer a question as to okay
why did we have set up hidden States and
observations and actions in that way why
are we doing these like identity
mappings between particular things um by
learning the a matrix that will allow
our agent to learn if it's the case that
when it explores it'll be more likely to
see an improvement or uh or no
improvement right this will allow our
agent to by accumulating observations
over time in the action perception Loop
um it will begin to better update uh its
beliefs about which thing it should do
and so even though we you know
previously we defined e as being uniform
over those two actions to where the
agent initially had no particular um you
know bias towards exploring or
exploiting it will actually probably
start to bias the agent towards one of
those directions because it prefers to
see improvements and that can only occur
through learning uh without learning and
modifying internal uh parameters of your
model you're effectively uh you know
sort of like a
pre-programmed uh uh Theros thermostat
or something right you're
nonadaptive you just act in the same way
as you always do and so an agent who
doesn't learn as the one if we Define an
agent like we just did but it never
learns then what it will do is more than
likely just with a 5050 chance choose to
explore or exploit just keep going uh
from there so um the way that we update
the a matrix for the PDP agent here um
is that we is quite simple and this is
it you don't even need all this code you
only need the code in the upper right
but it's basically this uh small P
capital A is the prior that we're
creating uh what we're doing is that
we're using that util subl Library this
de lay like function which basically you
construct your a send it through the
deerl like function it'll convert it
into what is a kind of Exemplar
conjugate distribution of a categorical
probability distribution uh that being a
de lay distribution it it affect
whenever you print it out you see that
we set scale to one it looks exactly
like our a matrix um what that scale
argument does is that it scales the
values that's the special thing about
the Matrix dlay distribution is that
it's something like an accumulation of
pseudo counts that will then weigh uh
you know
particular um comp parts of the the
competition of free energy minimization
uh for example the agent might start to
see more instances of improvement uh and
so it might start to upweight uh the the
likelihood of uh Improvement uh given
the association that it saw it with you
know and so the these don't actually
have to sum to one they're just kind of
like waiting our any Matrix and they're
very relatable to the notion of uh
Precision right like if a if an agent
hardly has any previous experience uh
with anything and it's and it's it's
it's U uh prior over a is highly scaled
down meaning it it has very few pseudo
counts of any prior experience uh it's
the agent is going to be less certain in
its ability to make connections between
uh exactly what the a matrix tries to
model which is the relationship between
observations and States so um so these
values can themselves you know be set
differently and and you can set the
Precision differently and then they can
impact the the agent uh
differently now we have all of that this
is it for constructing the agent uh it's
basically just an agent class and so you
just feed in the arguments they're
actually many many arguments uh that can
go into the agent Constructor um it
might seem like a lot there actually uh
I think literally a couple dozen more uh
but that it very much mirrors the
construction of the mat lab SPM package
for anyone familiar with that um there's
a whole script you know that that will
run through and and try and construct
your your markup decision- making
process your agent and it'll check to
make sure that all these uh you know
boxes are correct like is the a
normalized is you know how did you set
Gamma or some other thing and so it's
you know in spirit this is very similar
to that um what's nice is that the the
PDP package um it has different
inference algorithms um not many but uh
as opposed to choosing sort of the
standard one uh I've chosen
MMP uh which is marginal message passing
there's a nice paper on it that uh can
be found in the speaker notes of the
tutorial slides I make a brief reference
to it here part all
2019 and um so marginal message passing
basically being a kind of U you know in
a certain way it's a kind of compromise
between uh uh overcoming
intractability and and attaining
achieving something like computational
efficiency and approximation that you
get with variational message passing but
at the same time um it it it it it
overcomes some of the issues of not um
um having certain Precision terms
involved
that uh you know that leads to issues
with VAR variational message passing
that it it it can be uh it can lead to
overconfident posteriors in the
computation and meanwhile belief
propagation is much more holistic but um
more computationally expensive sometimes
tractable depending on the situation so
MMP is a nice way of striking balance uh
trying to M find that balance between
complexity and and and accuracy as we
are always trying to do right um
so you you'll notice uh that we plugged
in everything that we defined so far A B
CDE e and then the prior over a shows
MMP just a little bit more explanation
of what some of these other arguments
are um but uh given the time and also
simply the fact that I mean um we would
have to go into a lot more to look the
other options available I would say this
suffices um you know if you want to play
around with any of these um certainly go
for it and especially recommend looking
at inference Horizon in the policy
length uh arguments um this agent is
very simple in the sense that it makes
no future planning steps for for
constructing policies that go beyond
just should I explore now or should I
exploit now um it it can make
inferences one additional time step into
the future though so it does in a
certain way allow it to have this kind
of forward looking n where it'll not
just try to anticipate what will happen
next but it'll try to anticipate what
will happen next next so you know the
next time step and the one following
that um and
uh yeah I also chose stochastic action
selection you could choose deterministic
instead there's a note on how that works
um basically you know if uh if you're
posteriors over policies or that uh you
know U explore has a value of one you'll
choose that with probability .1 right so
there's still stochasticity involved um
but you're just going to be more likely
to choose the option with the highest
probability um deterministic means you
would automatically go for the the
action that has the highest probability
assigned in the
posterior so those things in mind uh
this is the general process uh that will
be carried out d in um an active
inference Loop for our agent it'll infer
States uh which you know once we've
constructed our agent uh the agent and
this is common for other reinforcement
learning paradigms as well um you you
have an agent and then that agent will
have a series of attributes that you can
access at any given time um this our
agents have an infer States method which
can then take in um the
observation and then after that uh
whenever it comes to learning uh the the
PIP install version of imdp has update a
b and d matrices uh available um there
are uh I I to briefly hearken back to
this there have been many updates to the
PDP Library over the past couple years
it's very exciting but uh I didn't want
to give anything too definitive because
I think many things are still in
progress but right now they're they're
acting developing means doing model
fitting uh which are already there uh
it's just I can see that they're they're
kind of cleaning some things up they've
also you know there there's a there will
be means of using the Jacks back in to
speed up a lot of the processes which is
very exciting and also they've
implemented a sophisticated inference uh
which is another way of doing policy
inference uh using a kind kind of
optimizing the tree search um but I uh
in addition to those updates uh they'll
also be updating the abilities such that
the agent could learn its preferences or
its habits uh or other aspect the
aspects these are just the the PIP
install versions uh currently available
methods then agent will infer its
policies and then it will sample its
action
um so inate inference again we're using
marginal message passing um interesting
thing about pmdp is that um the only
time that F variational free energy
really comes up as far as the code goes
is that um f gets uh scored across
policies rather than being the more
General free energy of the overall
system per se but in certain ways from
looking at the raw code that carries
that out uh it appears that you know
there are other aspects involved um but
for the sake of the tutorial we'll just
say what interesting is that uh free
energy is the same for both actions at
any given point in time and I think that
in part is due to the fact that the
complexity term uh in uh V defining
variational free energy for each um
action or policy um it's dependent on
this uh the posteriors Over States
versus uh your your prior which starts
to look like your be Matrix regarding uh
State Transitions and the agent has
fully uh predictable fully uh you know
identity mapping one to one mapping in
its B transition matrices and I think
that's what actually brings this
complexity term uh down to uh virtually
zero right uh it's like the the
posteriors are basically matching what
it it it knows what state it'll
transition to and if it doesn't ever
look learn its B Matrix and never has
any opportunity otherwise to see
something different from what it already
believes then it's as if the agent fully
believes like okay you know complexity
is gone all it's left with is accuracy
and so it's accuracy actually the
difference between observations and
States that's what's going to lead to
the fluctuations in the variational free
energy but this is all the code you need
a really important part is the way that
this OBS Ops uh variable or object is
defined again it's very important to
keep track of your indices um at any
point in time you could you could Define
an OBS object like this which is a list
the first element of OBS corresponds to
the first observation modality which for
us was outcome and then the the value
itself refers to the index of the
particular observation in question so
what we're saying here is the first
value representing the observation
modality outcome modality um that first
value zero is index to Improvement and
you can see that same logic uh plays out
for the second element in the Ops list
um you know this is for the attention
observation modality and zero
representing self as you know what it's
indexed to and so it's as if the agent
just observed that it was attending to
it itself and it saw an
improvement we simply run that through
uh the agent. in first States method uh
and plug into Ops and then the agent
will update uh it'll find Qs meaning
it's it's posteriors over hidden States
and uh those will actually get stored in
the agent as an attribute as well but um
but the the method Returns the object
and so I'm you know we're keeping it
here Qs and then you can look um we we
didn't have to explicitly say anything
about Computing F it's just this INF
first States um uh run then led to uh an
internal computation of f in the agent
that we can now access
print so this starts getting into um let
speed through this a little bit but
because I already touched on various
things but this is another breakdown you
know it's very useful to look at the
different breakdowns of uh variational
free energy and expected free energy and
so on um but I'm GNA move through this
slide and come because we'll get back to
policy inference shortly
uh this uh this is to show that Qs the
posteriors over hidden States uh is
rather complex whenever you use the
marginal message
passing um uh algorithm uh but it's also
very interesting in that the the way it
gets broken down itself being a rather
complex threedimensional matrix it's
that the First Dimension refers to
policy um if if we if we kind of open it
up as it were um and the second one
where uh is the time step and the third
is the hidden State Factor so what this
is saying is that um for the first entry
uh which relates to explore and then the
time step if you make you know the first
entry of that means now and then in
state Factor we only have one of them so
the first entry is the only entry the
attention in state factor that
effectively means if you print Qs uh 0
comma 0 comma 0o uh it'll print out this
first value representing this is what
the agent believes to be the hidden
State given the policy um you know given
the Explorer policy and so we can
actually extract that out whenever I
have these slightly out of line um we
can extract that out and then
um Thea excuse me um this line here
agent. Qs uh we can we can uh extract it
out via Qs action sampled ID Z all that
means is uh we're grabbing the the
agent's posterior beliefs given the
actual hint state that it chose um that
there's a little bit of complexity and
it get it's it's much much clearer in
the Google collab script um that I've
included so I advise having a look at
that um but this is the code that allows
the agent to uh update its a matrix uh
the only reason why uh we need a couple
extra lines of code is because of the
complex structure of the Qs that um
comes out um of a marginal message
passing
agent and
then we'll look
at
um um policy inference you saw that
there are more slides than what I really
need to explain it but um this is the
final step of the action perception Loop
so for policy inference your posterior
beliefs over your policies uh in this
case are um your negative expected free
energy
times gamma which uh have a better slide
to represent
that here we are um gamma which is your
action Precision so just as I mentioned
like um we can we can put these uh hyper
priors or parameters on our a matrix to
learn the a matrix and and and that
scale argument kind of kind of um down
Tunes or uptunes the Precision on the a
matrix similarly here um we can we can
downtune or uptune uh the the Precision
over G uh expected free energy and since
expected free energy is what is directly
involved in real izing one's preferences
I mentioned earlier with C matrix it's
kind of like whenever we look at this
equation is that we're seeing uh a sort
of balancing act between expected free
energy related to sort of deliberate
decision making to realized goals uh you
know these are very contextual you know
uh kind of beliefs and and and uh ways
of computing free energy and then you
have variational free energy which uh
you know is sort of like the the free
energy of the present um and it doesn't
necessarily take into account anything
regarding uh preferences uh you know the
C Matrix and what you say you want to
see uh it's more about just kind of
optimizing your model in the moment and
then uh habits which we already touched
on earlier um and then those uh we take
the we actually take the natural log of
those so that they kind of fit similarly
on the same scale with expect to free en
energ and variational free energy so
it's kind of like you have these three
different you know you have your habits
built up from the past you have your
variational free energy of the present
and then you have your expected free
energy of the future all sort of
contending with one another and then
being run through this soft Max function
which as we saw earlier uh when we used
it for the C Matrix um that converts it
into something that sums to one and then
axes our um uh categorical probabilities
distribution and the number of entries
will be equivalent to the number of
actions you have available and so that
will look like um in the case of G alone
uh it'll it'll look like this you'll
have your uh free energy for uh the
explore action and your free energy for
the exploit action and recall that uh
that we want to minimize this quantity
so it's actually the the quantity with a
smaller number that's uh better so to
speak um and then these values will get
plugged into the policy inference
equation up top in addition to what we
already saw earlier the variational free
energy values we saw and then the habits
which we programmed even earlier than
that so we have now all of components
for constructing an active inference
agent we have all the components needed
for doing uh hidden State inference of
of having our agent receive observations
that it uses to receive uh to to infer
hidden States and then to infer policies
and to to select an action uh that
that's what this slide represents is the
ability to uh infer policies um you can
print out G and have a look at it uh and
then with sample action this is just
basically has the agent sample from
it's posterities over policies and then
this act this extra code here is simply
because um you know the whenever you
have the agent sample in action it
returns it within a list uh and so we
need to extract that out of there
um and
then these last two slides were to
represent uh two example simulations
that I ran um they're I'm sure they look
rather busy as many of these other
slides have but there's just so much to
kind of look at and get into um with
this figure attempts to do is that you
can lead it read it from left to right
uh time like over time steps um from the
start of a simulation to the end in this
case it was 30 time steps
long and then you can also read it from
top to bottom uh where the agent
receives an observation it computes
variational free energy um it learns
it's a
matrix it infers policies and the
expected free energy of each action uh
it it uh along with that that g then
gets included along with f and habits to
compute um posterior beliefs about
policies and then uh finally the agent
chooses an action that gets sent in so
it's kind of like from left right we're
looking at each time step where a whole
uh action perception Loop is happening
and then vertically we're looking at an
entire uh action perception Loop or you
could flip that say perception action
Loop given Ag and is getting getting an
observation first
right and so uh in this simulation I'll
just stick with this one uh but uh you
know in in this
simulation
uh the agent
um receives an initial observation uh it
just forced it to say like self and and
Improvement know it seems good um or
excuse me it gets initialized with with
Improvement and neighbor and then for
the first half the simulation we're in
what I'll call the neighbor context
where in that case uh the simulation is
uh you know it's programmed in a loop so
the agent will receive um
it will always receive uh an improvement
if they exploit and they'll always
receive a no improvement if they explore
so you can see this is a very
deterministic uh and very extreme
environment where uh you know choosing
to explore always leads to a bad outcome
for the agent choosing to exploit always
leads to a good outcome for the agent
and so during the first couple steps
call that our agent starts off with um
you know these uniform beliefs uh as far
as its habits go of whether it should
explore or
exploit uh and so that's where these red
and blue lines and this probability uh
subgraph here subplot uh they line up
with one another they're 0. 5.5 so
effectively the agent is just kind of
randomly choosing one of these two
options and it just happens it choose to
explore both times
whenever it chose to explore both times
for the next two time steps it saw that
there were uh no improvement like bad
outcomes um you know given that and uh
the the agents free variational free
energy of the present uh kind of uh kind
of got jerked downward uh in a in a good
way it's meaning that it's informative
to the agent during those time steps to
see that it's accumulating evidence that
it's seeing that it it might be learning
something and in the meantime during the
second time step the agent learned its a
matrix right so um that also means that
there was a lot of updating in its
internal model uh that has led to
changes in its free energy as well and
then over
time uh things start to diverge the
agent quickly realizes oh if I exploit I
receive this green Improvement
observation again and again so the agent
proceeds to uh exploit and it actually
does it all the time as it's doing it
it's seeing that there's less and less
expected free energy to just exploit um
and then similarly in the final policy
inference it it actually reaches um you
know a 1.0 probability that the agent
should exploit to where the agent is
effectively doing this
deterministically uh practically given
that it keeps inferring that and also
this yellow line is especially
interesting um and and part of why I
wanted to do all this in the first place
what this yellow line is doing is that
this is me extracting out from it um the
probability of the agent seeing an
improvement uh given that it attended to
its neighbor which links up with
exploiting so this is teaching the agen
that uh it should keep exploiting um
it'll see improvements it'll get What It
Wants it'll keep going that way right
this agent is adapting to an environment
where um you know the that's exactly how
this world works right and then halfway
through the
simulation uh everything is reversed so
now uh we went from one environmental
extreme to another in the first case the
agent saw improvements uh from attending
to its neighbor now the agent will only
see improvements from attending to
itself and it only see no improvements
when attending to its neighbor and
because there have been so many
instances in its past experience of
seeing beneficial outcomes when it
exploits its neighbor um the agent now
actually has to
unlearn what it is learned right um and
by the end of the simulation still
hasn't fully done that um
and uh we we can see this reflected in
uh the um expected free energy the it
starts to rise again for exploit as the
agent no longer sees any more
improvements even though uh it's
continuing to exploit because that's
what it expects so this is a toy
simulation in that you might not have
learning happen after every two times
steps that's a very arbitrary thing that
I've chosen to do and it's actually a
rather rapid learning rate all things
considered more often than not whenever
setting up a simulation you'll have an
agent who might say learn at the end of
a trial where you run 10 Trials of Three
Time steps each or something along those
lines right um it's less common to run
trials over 30 time steps however uh in
more traditional agent-based modeling uh
paradigms because of their Simplicity
you often do run
uh you know a simulation over many many
time steps right and so I want to make
sure that this code is set up in a way
that you could run this as long as you
you know prefer to without without too
much complexity because I wanted to show
the value to computational social scien
as to what they might be able to do um
with with active inference agents but
now that we're uh significantly Beyond
uh you know where where I wanted to wrap
up um I'll just take one more minute to
say um you know there again there is um
you can land at the
GitHub uh you know website that I made
it's very short to the point and all the
links here are uh available for the
slides that I was just showing there are
many more slides I tried to be rather
comprehensive uh given uh you know how
much material I'm trying to show and
then uh the two collab scripts with this
second one being a further development
of the original code but I'm adding more
explanatory mark off uh excuse mark off
uh markdown uh cells that uh kind of
better describe things uh including
giving examples of how uh the a matrix
works and the B Matrix works and
furthermore again I I repeatedly
emphasize like being able to get your
Matrix construction and structuration
down I actually provided code on here's
how you create you know an a matrix and
you can
manually uh Define the values it's a
good idea to learn how to manually
Define the values of the a matrix or of
the me the B Matrix um it looks rather
tedious than it is but to be able to do
them one by one is a great sort of
dactic means of like learning how to
construct these including whenever we
get into these more complex like ways of
um you know representing probability
distributions where you have three or
more Dimensions but once you're able to
do that you might just at some point
realize oh there's a loop I could write
that could do this for me um but you
don't quite know what that Loop looks
like until you kind of get a sense of
what value should be there right so um
anyway so the it's the point is that
there are just some additional uh tools
and information that can be used here
and then all the code is available for
say uh printing out like running the
example simulations and then looking at
the plots at the end feel afraid to you
know modify and adapt those um as as
pleases you so um that's all I have for
today and I would love in future to give
another uh talk Andor pre-record
something that goes into a lot of the
other material and probably gives a more
kind of cursory overview of the rest
especially for people who would be
interested in um multi-agent simulations
and um and especially kind of using
leveraging packages like Network X which
will allow you to kind of connect agents
and graphs and Define like sort of like
the relationships with one another and
it gives clever ways of of giving them
actions that are specific to only the
agents in their Network or other things
like that so um yeah that uh concludes
thanks nice great work um why or how
would somebody use it other than to get
a good handle on the PDP how would you
see it being used or adopted for
research
cool yeah yeah um so I think uh in
scenario like this kind of provides a
general agent who can like do things
that are defined as exploring or
exploiting and so
um what you could do is use it to you
know create the the ink landscape laser
Freedman model that I I mentioned
earlier uh and then and then tweak
things from there or you could use this
as a more General template like take out
the idea that these are attention and
outcome modalities and stuff swap them
out for you know whatever you want this
can have like the template is here for
including as many observation modalities
in state factors as you want for example
uh just change the names and make sure
you define the ab CDs you know uh to
your liking and so that that's really
what I wanted to do just create like
here here's here's an example agent
because we need to know what the final
picture should look like but um you know
from there just just tear it apart and
like you know to to your hearts content
and and make it into to what you want to
see these agents can be used to you know
um the idea of autonomous decision
making that if there are any discrete
number of things that you'd want to set
up some kind of agent to do and you know
what kind of data you want it to read um
you know and what what should be the
impact of each of those discrete actions
it has like you have this as a kind of
like agent that you can plug into uh
that that sort of design diagram right
so big answer it's pretty abstract sorry
but yeah cool what will be coming up for
the next several
weeks cool yeah um so with the Symposium
I'm looking forward to giving a talk
that's a little bit more uh to the
script uh and less focused on coding and
more on how these kinds of things might
be applied in social science research uh
including looking at uh you know some
other research that has also been done
uh just to try and give a a sense that
is in fact a sort of subfield forming
here and of course we have the the
course on social science done with the
with the Institute itself last year and
um you know different people making
Headway in that area so um looking
forward to that and uh who who knows
what else uh i' very much look forward
to maybe presenting some other research
where I'm using agents like this and
having them interact in kind of
interesting ways with let's say
LMS um and you know these become a kind
of uh fun uh way of trying to imagine
autonomous decision making whenever it
comes to things like prompting so
yeah cool well the video description has
the
links and where things will be
versions and it's a great demo so thank
you any other comments
you um not not currently aside from you
know uh thanks everyone who uh joined
the textbook group and uh you know over
the recent reading uh we're currently
talking through uh other ways that we
might go about the textbook group going
forward but we had a really nice wrapup
conversation yesterday so looking
forward to Future
talks cool okay thank you again Andrew
looking forward to the
next episodes in the
series yeah thanks Daniel thank you
peace take
care for